das im bild mit bis jetzt hat die kerze
ich bin jetzt auf einer relativ freien
fläche ich sehe dem mond ich glaube
dieses kumpel diese kupfer spitzhacke
die ist genauso gut wie eine eisenplatte
hält länger habe ich das gefühl und der
sah den dschungel es war ein riesiger
dschungel
sie würden sich verlaufen aber sie
hatten die minimap drin sehr cool wenn
man auch wenn ich dich auf der minimap
sehen würde kann man auch wie ein also
mit mit dem eltern oder so aber svp
servern zu vertreten ein spieler gesehen
hat ist der dschungel groß ist er aber
groß es war richtig groß egal ich laufe
durch ich habe ihnen die box anschauen
ich habe mich welche karten bist ja ich
bin die koordinaten 3 109 - 93 bis zu 24
- 360 plus 460 oder fast ident fast
beieinander
dann müssen wir jetzt mal uns treffen
ich bin ich jetzt fast oben glaube ich
bin aber so berg ich bin schon höher 70
aus dem erste erste sind aus diesem eine
praktikantin im berg hoch ich bin höre
96 in dem werk auf dem wiener ich glaub
ich den berg hoch egal
vorne raus ich will wieder raus auf
platz acht
ich bin - 360 und 460 hab ich da hoch
und dann hör 909 109 100 bist du ich bin
im berg und ist gerade noch erlaubt sein
inventar schon voll alter des kindes
ja ich bin draußen ich hab's geschafft
sie sind fackeln von dir
es heißt sie muss schon hier gewesen
sein ja wo bist du denn wo bist du denn
406 4 6 plus 430 folge - 41 6 430 aber
ja ich sehe dann habe ich sie dann armen
wo bist du denn ich bin muss den berg
hoch kürzeln stirbt zombie studios war
die stickige luft drin die bergarbeiter
eine deine koordinaten meine koordinaten
sind jetzt mit mehr als 400 + 44
ich erwarte ich komm genau dahinter okay
ich bin bereit ich bin weit ich bin weil
ich bin direkt linie unter die ersten
drei zu kommen
ich komme bei the jungle schau da mal
lang altert ist das nicht riesig das ist
was ist das da geht's richtig ab
es wird richtig habe aufsagen wir
versuchen jetzt irgendwo unterzukommen
sollte aber möglich seien unbeschadet ja
auch geschafft
nico popp und kann natürlich immer mit
aaa schaden bekommen so wird sein habe
ich kenne den jungen einfach und laufen
als erstmal einfach durch
hier ist natürlich eine rolle jedoch
nicht doch nicht schade ich spinne ich
halte spinne und dieses sexpuppe die
kraft das gefällt mir
unerwartet gut ein bisschen kommt
überdies gebauter gestürzt neben mir
mein alter du läufst direkt rein es
genau in mir explodiert ist alter wie
gestalte ich hab nur vier herzen
bekommen gut heraus gerissen aber ich
glaube meine rüstung hat nämlich so viel
scheint also ein krieg bei überleben
mich schon ein bisschen wir jetzt hinter
die halter sodann lisandro falsche
richtung
ich kenne den dschungel aus nein ich
etwas falsches rausgeworfen rauswerfen
arbeiten
ich habe 40 oder rausgeworfen ich wollte
vielleicht setzlinge rausschmeißen so
hier entlang weiter dort entlang der
rente
hier ist diese sind jetzt die tempel das
ist ein
das ergibt das einen tempel es ist die
relative warum will das ist nur dieses
mal das ist voll auf den höhlen
warum will warum sollten hierzu mal
einfach so sein
ja das war auch voll in der höhle das
sind einfach so ersatz zum stein sag ich
mal
ich glaube da nehme ich mir erst mal mit
ja davon als mitglied von der iss aus
ja ich glaube schon das weiße haus hat
vergleich wetter raus angeboten machen
ich hab schon so viel in meinem club ist
voll appetit freue mich auch nicht
kiesbauer nicht so da komme ich jetzt
einfach ein bisschen mit marmor
marmorstein lieben ist ein komischer
stein
es ist dies ist ein amberger model in
embrace bord richtig runter mit diesem
ganzen marmor
ich habe ein steak marmor 43 das reicht
mir das mal okay warum hin dass du
einfach weiter durch den dschungel wo
was ist das das ist dort jetzt ist das
alu hast du uns zufällig eisen dabei ja
ich bräuchte drei eisenerz was kriege
ich dafür drei silber drei silber- oder
vielleicht alles rubin oder so was
willst du vielleicht dafür zwei kupfer
ich hätte gerne rubin problem habe ich
nicht oder ich hab red cocks thorium
oder hassaba 4 sa 4 1 quarzkristall hab
ich hast du green sehr viel
ja aber ich werde dann gebt mir ein
green saphir dann geb ich dir drei eisen
du willst nicht über den tisch ziehen ja
okay das denn drei eisen ganze haben
sagt weis ich euch zu bauen möchte ist
wo ist denn hier meine sache umgehen ich
musste mir ganz kurz ein wolfsmensch
born war ich möchte nämlich heuer die
hinausgeht auch schon da und soll dem
bund geht unter das heißt die sonne geht
auf das heißt ich versuche jetzt eine
höhere position zu finden dann zeige ich
euch mal als zombie der kanzel springen
und alles was ich wollte mir world benz
bauen so meine lieben freunde wir schon
zu den sonnenuntergang den sonnenauf
oder gefallen
eine wordpress hier baue ich mir jetzt
aus den drei heissen so freue mich mit
802 aufgang hier im dschungel an
ich habe mir jetzt gerade eine schere
gemacht und jetzt flog ich mir hier das
krieg ich mir hier die diese idee ab
ich bin konnte bei dir
er ist aber auch keine richtige würde es
geht ja auch schon länger aus dem
dschungel kannst du keine richtige
balance finden sich auch mit dem schnitt
ist man raus
okay das ist weil da hinten ist da
besonders an ist schritt dahin gehen
damit die sonne aufgeht komm lass uns
bitte geradeaus weitergehen uns
verlieren die orientierung also hier
warten die giganten ist auch schon bei
jungen das kannst du eigentlich ein
kraftakt boni von daher sowohl ihren so
hier findet ihr bestimmt welche will man
mal kurz
ich brauche so wirklich ammann ärgerlich
installieren und wieder wartet kurz
natürlich ein bisschen der namen die mir
ich bin einfach weiter richtung ja ich
komplett verschieden lang ist komme ich
habe einen ganz kurzen bisschen sand
abgegangen genommen da war schon weg da
bist du
career day seine skelette hieße doch
dass eine höhle glaube ich ja auch das
marmor
hier ist eine hülle auch nicht wirklich
ne oder doch wenn man hinten blitz hat
irgendwas ja du kannst daran gehen ich
will noch so eine nebenhöhlen gefunden
einer nebenhöhlen zu nennen ich glaube
ich gehe da einfach mal rein
oh ja oh ja eine sehr sehr große hürde
die ich hier gefunden habe zwei blöcke
groß locker ich finde man die höhlen
zeigt überdies sind die post ab ach du
bist du schon wieder unten drin jetzt
berlin
na gut aber monats ich hab' ich habe ein
monat zieht gefunden
was ist das denn ich fahr weitere grün
sachen ich weiß nicht ich ablegen soll
dafür korn kernel die sachen dann
bekommt du willst doch ihr vater von
david meister werden bei hitze oder
schläge bekommen filmskript sie
wegschmeißen soll ich das jetzt einfach
nur ein vogel die andere ganze land
bringt er zu schmeißen weiter runter
geworfen
mit 16 morden steckt der bogen
runtergeworfen ach jetzt auch noch am
eingang ist also eine fette fläche hier
geht's lang und hier ist gott ist das
sehr groß ok ich würde sagen diese höhle
werden wir das problem ist weil man kurz
weiß was ich selbst zwei kleine kiste
für dich als ziemlich okay okay aber man
merkt ihr was märkte wo wir die
platzieren ich kann unseren freund
machen
okay da machen weil ich möchte erstmal
den zombie töten der sieht mir sehr blöd
aus
ach ja viele doppel kiste gemacht so
oder so ein pressing bekomme ich doch
ein gutes ewigen geblieben er setzt die
weiter auseinander dann die kisten über
meiner kiste ist eine fackel dass meine
moment hast du schild dabei bastian
finke erst die rechte fertig sagte noch
alles da rein
lolo jones lang lasalle poncet höhlen
kiste danach ist man hier auf diese
deckungssumme kiste ja dann oder als ich
bin da unten mal runter jetzt nicht
anders verdient konnten sehe ich da war
ich gehe einfach mal runter laden hat
mich immer so ein bisschen das
gefährlich aber könnten diamant sein